what plays has Daniel rackliffe been in
I did a play called Eis um which people
probably know as being the play about a
psychologically Disturbed kid who is
obsessed with horses and gets naked
that's the detail you probably remember
I did that when I was 17 which seems
crazy to say out loud now but I did I
did a play by Martin McDonna uh called
the of enish man that was a lot
of fun I did a musical called How to
Succeed In Business Without Really
Trying I'm I just I'm just listenting my
CV for you now but that's fine I want to
go back to Broadway at some point um and
and the West End oh I did endgame I did
endgame in London it's right before the
pandemic as well that's the most recent
that's embarrassing that that I forgot
that one I love I love film as well but
like stage you get a pure Adrenaline
Rush every night which is really really
exciting and and addictive